what is a lich the word legend both
archaic english and german means corpse
or kadavo a lich is often a powerful
sorcerer or king who has achieved
immortality they achieved this by
binding their intellect and soul into a
small object often a charm or an amulet
this is now a phylactery once the
physical body dies they are reincarnated
by their phylactery
and they live on as a lich a modern
example of this would be in Harry Potter
but we see Lord Voldemort store parts of
his soul into objects known as Horcruxes
meaning that he cannot be killed until
all the Horcruxes are destroyed a lich
cannot be killed until the phylactery
has been destroyed resulted in them
having no real weaknesses Alette whose
power can be seen as limitless as they
are no longer held back by constraints
such as mortality they have all the time
to practice their skills and acquire
knowledge their bodies often appear
desiccated withered flesh stretched
across horribly visible bones in some
places they appear completely skeletal
they often appear as zombie like however
there are some drastic differences
between the two when one becomes a lich
they retain all the knowledge and powers
that previously had
unlike zombies they remain a
single-minded entity or as zombies are
more of a hive mind and are driven by
the need to devour flesh they are often
depicted as holding power of a lesser
undead creatures being able to use them
as servants or soldiers whenever needed
as a large amount of lecherous sorcerers
in their previous lives the weapon of
choice appears to be an enchanted staff
with those who were Kings still wielding
swords recent adaptations showed him
being able to wield Frost magic as well
as cast necrotic spells
the Lich rose to popularity in the 1970s
and 80s through the board game Dungeons
& Dragons in the early 2000s the litter
appeared in blizzards Warcraft universe
as none other than Arthas the Lich King
himself
the Lich's appearances in mainstream
media seems have been limited in recent
years however with characters such as
Lord Voldemort from the Harry Potter
franchise and the knight king of Game of
Thrones the characters popularity in the
role of the main villain seems to be
growing there isn't too much information
around about the knight king and some of
you may disagree with me as I believe
the knight king is in fact a lich may
not possess all of the traits that you
associate with a lich however some of
the similarities are uncanny
he's withered face and bony exterior
means that he looks the part he also
seems to have control of a vast armies
of the undead he even has the ability to
turn others including creatures into
undead servants that would do his
bidding with the increase in popularity
of the lich in mainstream media we might
just be seeing more of our bony friend
in the future if you've enjoyed this
video then please go ahead and leave it
a like consider subscribing if folklore
mythology is something that interests
you if you have anything you'd like to
discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please go ahead and let me
know in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
folklore explain